bene di ragazzi e beve niente non ce la
faccio non so io mi tornerà prima o poi
questa voi non lo posso perdere per 62
anni che gioco è allora a parte il fatto
che è disegnato benissimo mi piace
tantissimo su steam e ho preso una
carcassa di ratto grande che bella tra
l'altro se posso se giampiero insomma
chi beve grazie giampiero perché è
proprio la nota grazie davvero
ho trovato una chiave grazie alla
carcassa di ratto va bene è la chiave la
liu jo per madonna ravetto cui ahimè
ringrazia posso riprendere la carcassa
di ratto mi tengo la cabina di regia ma
c'è una scala io mi porto il mio topino
tal senso ho sentito un rumore a destra
fuorché adryan per le brevi finita così
va bene bravi mente devo fare tutto di
fila c'è questa cosa veramente quadrata
prendiamo la carcassa di ratto e
corriamo al piano di sotto
devo trovare una chiave piccolina per
quel coso va bene il cassetto non si
apre o che va bene vado avanti con la
carta senatopri a porta è aperta
tiriamo alta uno spazzolino cosa pulisco
con questo la carta senato l'ho lasciata
peccatore che mi interessava madonna non
sa c'è una scatola sola in sostanza cioè
dove vuoi che sia
vabbè usciamo
tutta natura premio fregato vice o
arrivederci ma sarebbe tana sarà anche
le scale michiara che non dall'inizio
dai o che sta salendo a sinistra bene
quindi posso andare giù la cava che di
qua c'è anche c'era anche una lucertola
anno cosa una lumaca fair il pitch ha
forse sarà che va dietro attenzione mi
devo dare un'occhiata devo controllare
ma don devo controllare per beni gli
occhi della tipa perché gli occhi
relativa mi dicono esattamente dove sta
la tizia colpi siano stati unti sale non
oggi però mi dicono esattamente dove sta
se ci fate caso gli ha posto sul libro
aveva non si apre porca [ __ ] cosa mi
faccio in un libro il santo dio sta
correndo di quadra che sta sentendo che
c'è il televisore aceto ardant madonna è
l'aspetto del non ha un occhio tra
l'altro non ha o no questa cosa assurda
cioè a un occhio finta un occhio più
basso vabbè lasciamo perdere
posso bruciare questo libro come faccio
il suo libro minchia di oggettivo
giocando tanto cosa servono
un libro cosa serve a per raggiungere un
altura c'è una lo marca con degli occhi
umani e non è neanche la cosa più brutta
che ho visto finora
ok cazzo ma sento che quando vado a cena
tra patate
non è vero
[Musica]
ai media era chiuso ma dalla porta ma è
difficilissimo era chiuso proprio ma
parco demonio che è andato lì sopra
veramente non so come fare questa parte
perché devo chiudere la porta aspettare
dai mori
l'arancio oddio oddio bisognare però c'è
chi aveva poi questo ti prego
kat era una chiave piccolissima serviva
ad aprire il caso di sopra quello del
questo qua che sta qua dentro
praticamente però mi piace non ci sono
nasconde il problema ragazze che la non
ci sono nascondigli non mi posso
nascondere mai è impossibile da fare
quella parte perché non puoi fare tutto
questo e nascondere due canzoni nascono
non puoi nasconderti stanzione non ti
puoi nascondere di qui sei morto a
prescindere ok tutto visto nascondiglio
praticamente la soluzione che cosa
avessi trovato prima madonna che culo ma
arriva la zia che non ha concluso maschi
la mano magari se ne vorrebbe ok entra
l'attento non c'è nessuno esce forse
posso andare bella bella bella perfetto
celo celo non sono mai arrivato fin qua
yes questo e poi tirano ma non mi sono
messo quale ha fatto k casini fa casino
fa casino non è una cosa non è un rumore
buono questo ecco cosa ha proposta
chiave cosa ci può aprire ragazzi e la
porta tutta a destra me lo sento
non lo so adattare a yes non lo sapevo
lo sentivo non so perché ho cristo sotto
il letto benissimo cos'è un accendino
che che sono il serve un accendino scusa
o cristo l'altra che due chiavi porca
vacca un'altra chiave cosa mi servirebbe
aspetta mai pensare
c'è un'altra porta chiusa ma non mi
ricordo quale è forse quella al piano di
sopra non è questa
proprio qui sotto è sparito rispetto
libro allora eccola la porta che si apre
questa qua è era quella era quella era
quella ok però è sparito il libro
proprio che da cellino l'ha chi scende
normale nel suo nome non ci vedo che c'è
anche questa riportano vabbè dai poteva
vedere innanzitutto le porte poi vediamo
cosa accendere questa cosa che va beh ok
perfetto perfetto cos'è sta roba ordigno
cos'è cos'è
no ragazzi non ci credo che la porta a
capitana cos'è qui dentro c'è ma dai ma
[ __ ] c'era una scala chiavari e
basta per l'argentino sono la faccia ce
la fa ce la faccio le scotte vanno allo
us nel basement vado alla ragazza
orribile stato mi basta spegnerlo no
praticamente per un ascia vuol dire
animo avanti prima aiuta certo così
eccolo libro che fa quali vivono solo
secolo fatta fin qua sotto
aprendo il libro poiché over da ics
addio quali cari corio di aver adoperato
da malta la madonna
basta che la faccia o dica dove cazzo
amato come uscita lì mi chiami chiaro no
ragazzi
no ragazzi cosa cazzo fatto cosa ho
fatto
c'è pazzesco un fenomeno madonna che
ansia di vivere
ma che cosa cacchio appena giocato
ragazzi gioco nel secolo tra l'altro io
non dormirei mai più altro che
abbracciare il pupazzo salve io stavo
tornando però a casa mia e questa
marcatura sì ma io vivo la sua non c'è
nessun adulto che vi con troppa dai ma
dai
noi ce ne succeda noi veramente non so
perché finale è manco a casa mia ma
anche in camera mia lo fanno entrare ma
che è polizia date una mano sta bambina
la cui è possibile ragazzi che bel gioco
cacchio ma bello bello c'è proprio non
ha scritto ormai iori spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto è veramente bello c'è
bisogno mi è piaciuto un sacco strada
difficilissimo poi non me lo aspettavo
maisto finale però difficilissimo ma
bello niente spero vivere sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosa che non mi piace fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate del gioco ma è
incredibile che come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]